ou non megaman merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france en direct alors augmenter
le nombre de lits de réanimation en
quelques semaines
est ce que c'est possible alors en fait
quand on parle d'augmenter le nombre de
lits de réanimation ou parle de la
création de lits de réanimation éphémère
c'est à dire de lit or deux secteurs
habituellement destinés à la réanimation
pour y pratiquer propre probablement ce
que l'on appelle une réanimation
dégradée c'est-à-dire des soins à des
patientes qui aurait dû être dans un
service de réanimation classique mais
qui faute de place devront être prises
en charge sur des lits en dehors des
secteurs de l'animation
évidemment l'objectif c'est de faire le
mieux possible pour se rapprocher de la
qualité des soins qui sera prodigué dans
les vrais lits pérenne de réanimation
alors on admis admettons un qu'il ait de
la place pour installer à ces lits quel
personnel pour s'en occuper
alors évidemment comme vous imaginez il
n'y a pas de personnel on travaille pas
un hôpital qui attend éventuels patients
ce dont on a la charge ou peut être plus
souvent il s'agit de personnel aux biens
des blocs opératoires au moment où on va
on va dire interrompre certaines
interventions chirurgicales programmées
non urgents ce sont des infirmiers
anesthésistes des infirmiers travaillent
aux blocs opératoires et qui sont donc
redéployer vers les secteurs de
renouvellement crée donc des personnes
seront capables de prodiguer des soins
de réanimation alors ce sont des
personnes qui ont appris évidemment les
techniques de réanimation en tout cas
dans le mode d'exercice se rapproche le
plus de ce des paramédicaux qui
travaillent habituellement v d'imation
évidemment il leur faut une petite
formation pour réactualiser leurs
connaissances mais globalement ça reste
active même si comme vous le dites
évidemment très clairement un personnel
qu'il soit médicale
exerce depuis plusieurs années en
réanimation
probablement un des meilleurs étant ce
qu une personne qui en a eu dans le
passé des déserts ce bloc opératoire
alors le gouvernement excluant le tri
des patients c'est pourtant ce que
craignaient les médecins de l'ap-hp
comme vous qui est en première ligne
pour quelles raisons les propos du
gouvernement
peuvent-ils nous rassurer écoutez le tri
est contre toute éthique médicale
donc quand mais qu'at il n'y aura pas de
tri à nouveau je précise le mot pris un
peu vague
ce que nous entendons c'est le tri sur
des critères de capacité à dire par
absence de lits et non bien sûr le tri
sur des critères médicaux pratiquer tous
les jours car quand vous imaginez être
admis en réanimation
peut-être offert à des patients une des
chances de s'en sortir avec les soins
difficile invasive agressif prolongée
qui vont prodiguer en réanimation donc
pardon voilà donc on va dire
effectivement vous sera fait bien sûr
pour pouvoir éviter que des patients qui
pourraient accéder un des leaders in
motion d'accès un bien sûr ce sera fait
à ce pouvoir aux déployer du personnel
parce qu'on va demander à des personnels
de faire des heures supplémentaires
parce qu'on va diminuer le ratio de
personnel soignant par rapport au nombre
de patients voyez donc on a un certain
nombre de solutions
malgré tout évidemment la qualité des
soins peu pourrait être dégradée
au final la crise sanitaire que l'on vit
actuellement at elle mis en lumière les
carences déjà existante de l'hôpital
public français oui tout à fait vous
avez raison donc effectivement voici une
vingtaine d'années que l'on réduit le
nombre de lits notamment réanimation
mais aussi dans toutes les autres
spécialités
on réduit le personnel soignant car
comme vous le savez la gestion de
l'hôpital public s'est fait uniquement
sur des critères comptables
or le personnel la ressource humaine et
là le poste budgétaire principal d'un
hôpital
donc si vous voulez réduire les dépenses
pour réduisez dans le personnel et si
vous devez réduire dans le personnel
vous réduisez dans le nombre de lits
alors évidemment on en est arrivé à un
système qui ne travaillent que en flux
tendu c'est à dire en fait qui ne peut
faire face à aucun afflux plus important
de patients par rapport au rythme
habituel
d'ailleurs et compris en année normale
dans les saisons d'hiver nous sommes
souvent pris en difficulté nous devons
transférer des patients à droite et à
gauche voir refuser ou décalés un sa
trempe de soins par ailleurs
effectivement même en termes de l'offre
de soins seules les activités médicales
ou chirurgicales dites rentables
économiquement parlant sont sont choisis
à l'inversé certaines activités peut
être coûteuse difficile et bien sont
négligés car évidemment la gestion de
l'hôpital n'était que comptable donc
nous réclamant bien sûr depuis longtemps
une modification de ces critères de
gestion une ouverture de deux là on va
dire de de la direction des hôpitaux aux
soignants eux mêmes comme vous le savez
le nombre de personnes qui travaillent à
l'hôpital et qui ne voit jamais de
patients qui sont uniquement dans les
bureaux a augmenté de façon
exponentielle depuis ces dernières
années et donc ceci à l'évidence
désormais nuit à la qualité des soins
alors on sait que le virus mute on ne
sait pas quel point les vaccins seront
efficaces sur les nouvelles mutations
sans vous prêter un don de visionnaire
arrivera-t-on un jour à maîtriser
l'épidémie dans un tel contexte
oui tout à fait donc effectivement virus
mute parce que il fait face à une
pression de sélection soit par
l'immunité naturelle qui est acquise par
les personnes qui ont fait l'infection
soit désormais évidemment par l'immunité
vaccinale le virus cherche bien sûr à
persister à infecter de plus en plus de
personnes et donc de fait il va
s'adapter et ce sont des souches les
plus contagieuses celles qui vont
développer des mécanismes de résistance
à l'immunité qui vont avoir la faveur et
remplacer les autres souches donc ces
phénomènes existent virus on le connaît
depuis longtemps donc de fait
effectivement il est possible dans les
années à venir il vaccin actuel
actuellement il est devenu inefficace ou
si vous nouvelle souche apparaissez
résistantes à ces vaccins il faille
mettre au point des vaccins annuellement
en l'occurrence ceci n'est pas un gros
problème puisque c'est le cas par
exemple simplement évidemment comme vous
l'avez compris même s'il s'agira de
vacciner en masse de la population
entière des pays bruno à mes gars ban
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
réanimateur chef du service de
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière de
paris mars